hi my name is andre jack and so far the
podcast has made one billion dollars no
it's a hundred grand
i think it would be nice
billion dollars one hundred thousand
dollars that's awesome congrats you guys
thank you so much you should have said
come for the coffee stay for the 100
thousand dollars you know the last time
i was here i broke another milestone too
i broke a million dollar an ad revenue
milestone if you don't know really yeah
it's total right not for the year but
not for the year total yeah wow yeah
congratulations yeah we should see each
other more often so we could bring more
milestones you know it's fine i think
we're almost about to do that for the
second channel we're getting very 1
million almost a million dollars in the
second channel whatever it is right now
we're going to put it on the screen yeah
for you guys to see that's awesome and
we've only had it for how long two years
two and a half years i think okay two
and a half years so about the same as
what i had my major right got it yeah
that's awesome anyway i feel like we
should introduce you so you are the uh
my arch rival nemesis personal finance
enthusiast on youtube
1.6
millie
what are you at right now i think 1.68
one point's okay but who's counting
1.65
but who's counting you make videos in
personal finance you do a lot of magic i
do which is really cool to watch when
you're doing these videos to incorporate
that into your editing and it's just
it's neat it's really neat stuff and you
were able to go from what was you
started a dividend portfolio remember
that's how you get started on youtube on
robinhood yeah there's making passive
income and then you've grown that into
what's that at now yeah so far i could
check can i pull it up or yeah yeah i
think it's a little over 400 now
um but i've kind of switched my strategy
so when i started i wasn't making as
much
so now that i'm in the highest tax
bracket i kind of dialed back to focus
more on broad market index funds which
makes a little bit more sense but so far
it's at
come on robin hood load
robin hood hey i love rolling what an
amateur
yeah it doesn't want to load here the
cryptobot guy buys all of his uh
stocks and as much as this
it's not loading
come on rob i don't know if it's your
service or what but anyway it's about
450 460 right now that's great and that
started from what and that started from
so when i quit youtube i think i had in
my portfolio about 150 170 when you quit
youtube sorry when i quit my job to
start oh okay yeah that was 170k around
which was about two and a half years ago
so i started january 2000 2019 yeah and
within two years i got to a million subs
luckily i don't know how i did it but
here it is and graham is uh my mini me
so what i think is really cool we had
you on the podcast uh wooden was back in
like february it was the beginning of
this year yeah and we were talking about
cryptocurrency and you were telling us a
little bit about the dangers of tether
and what was going on with bitcoin and
ethereum and back then that was just
like just as things were taking off so
what have you now noticed with
everything going on with el salvador
with currency prices just going crazy
and then just this flash crash that
recently happened what are your thoughts
on everything and have you changed your
own investing strategy for crypto no
it's honestly stayed the same but
exactly what i thought would happen is
happening which is now we're shifting
from institutional buying to now
countries
fighting for bitcoin and it seems like
if you're an early adopter then you know
it's helping those countries that don't
necessarily have strong currencies so
now we have ukraine i think was the
latest country that announced that they
made bitcoin legal and that's going to
have again a domino effect we're going
to have all these countries around
europe
that are going to start adopting bitcoin
it's only going to keep growing so why
would a country go and start adopting
bitcoin which is an alternative currency
to what they could be using and
promoting their own currency within said
government like why would they allow
bitcoin yeah that's a good question it's
because their currency is not strong
enough on a world scale
it's just not a strong currency against
the dollar right those countries are
printing their money away so their
currency has no purchasing power which
means you're if you're a citizen of
those countries
the price of goods is increasing every
day right so to have some sort of store
of value for those people they're trying
to put it all into bitcoin would it be
possible for them to create their own
currency like let's say el salvador
right instead of bitcoin they say hey
we're coming out with our uh el salvador
coin
everybody's gonna get x amount of this
coin you could redeem it for this we're
making this legal tender there's only
going to be so many of these like can't
they develop their own
yeah and then every country now like you
go to canada they have the canada coin
you come to the u.s you got it that
would be different from that than like
the us dollar it's just a digital it's
really just a digitalized dollar and
people might feel like it has less
impact for inflation
yeah well they are doing that right now
but not for the same purposes as they
would for bitcoin the reason they're
doing that is they just want to digitize
their currency right it's the same as
the us is doing here with fedcoin right
we're trying to create our own u.s
digital coin
and those countries are not trying to
recreate bitcoin and even if they did
nobody's going to start adopting that
currency's
currency as bitcoin they're not going to
just switch over because countries kind
of hate each other they're not going to
work together so bitcoin has that
strength of not being owned or
controlled by any single authority and
because no one lays claim to it
people feel like it's kind of neutral so
they want to buy it
that make sense yes isn't it a bit
dangerous though let's say for el
salvador
they they all get a certain amount of
current i think they were giving
everyone uh 30 of currency right if they
set up a wallet can you explain this in
depth a little bit more for some people
that may not know a lot about it the
viewers i'll let you explain it about el
salvador yeah no i'm not actually in the
family are they giving away 30 yeah yeah
oh graham
he's backed into a corner
do you know how to explain it graham are
you sure you can do this wait a minute
can we google this really no i'm kidding
all right okay so alex pull it up
hold up are we getting our citizenship
so let me explain so so to my knowledge
to my what they're doing is that they're
giving everyone thirty dollars a bitcoin
who signs up for a wallet and basically
implements this so that's their way
that's their incentive of getting people
in on the door and a lot of people just
don't know how to work it they're uh you
know it's like imagine trying to get
like your grandparent to understand how
cryptocurrency works get a wallet
address so they're thinking well you
know we throw 30 bucks uh that that's
going to bring enough incentive to to
make that happen but my concern was that
uh
literally the the the moment they
implement this is legal currency it
drops
15 in a matter of minutes and having
such a volatile currency now everybody
in el salvador who implemented this now
their money's worth 15 less in minutes
wait you said el salvador's making their
own coin or they're giving 30 of bitcoin
you're giving 30 a bitcoin
to their citizens who and why do you set
up that drop is happening
it's obvious it's got to be a whale i
mean
we don't know exactly
my understanding is that the reason of
the drop was that there was some sort of
whale who sold off a massive amount
triggered a whole bunch of margin calls
around the way um that lowered the price
of bitcoin to a point i think it was
like 42 where immediately people started
buying it back up kind of stopped that
loss then it's since recovered to about
46.47 and now it's kind of hovering
there that that's my understanding of it
yeah my understanding is just it's a
case of buy the room or sell the news
right like you said there's just some
whales that heard the news cool el
salvador's adopting it they're
implementing it sell it scare people buy
the dip it's just another opportunity
for them to take advantage of those
people who have no idea what they're
doing
but it's again it's a temporary drop and
that's what bitcoin does and these drops
are going to become less and less
substantial over time as more and more
countries start adopting it as the
market cap continues to grow yeah
so who do you think is going to be the
next country
well ukraine i think was the last one
um i could see
gosh i could see countries in africa
start adopting it
so it's illegal in quite a few countries
oh yeah it's illegal in a lot of
countries
yeah and it's interesting because the
countries that it's most illegal in are
the ones with the most censorship
it's the governments that are the most
corrupt and the most
the the countries that want to censor
the internet essentially those are the
ones that are not allowing bitcoin right
so
and they're the ones that need it the
most
absolutely they are the ones that need
it the most they are liberating those
countries bitcoin is liberating those
countries 100
yeah but then they give up control i
mean you have to think too if you're a
dictator and you want to control your
your entire country and just the the
masses
bitcoin
takes that control away right there's no
incentive for those people to want to
embrace bitcoin and so imagine if that
country that is censoring people did
create their own currency do you think
that people around the world are going
to be like oh el salvador created their
own currency i gotta buy into this
no one's gonna do that
that's why i don't see any country
trying to compete with bitcoin to any
relevant
point yeah i would love to see zimbabwe
yeah and incorporate bitcoin i would
love tina why is zimbabwe
are you are you not familiar with it no
please educate me are you actually not i
really am not okay zimbabwe has seen the
most inflation from any location in the
entire world and you would literally see
people with trillion dollar bills
trillions and they would have to walk
with the wheelbarrow of money there's
pictures on it just to buy a loaf of
bread like imagine a wheelbarrow of
money hundreds of trillions of dollars
to buy a loaf of bread and i forget what
their what their inflation was it was
something like thousands of percent a
year yeah like if you you if you by the
time you received money and spent it
it's lost value that's fast so i'm like
a zimbabwe quadrillionaire is what
you're saying yes and you know what's
funny well not really funny but uh it's
odd i think it's it's you know as a bit
of a souvenir people buy their currency
on ebay and you could say like you could
buy a hundred trillion dollar notes on
ebay for like i think it's like 20 bucks
something like that but i just i have a
collection from zimbabwe for those yeah
i think there's one million 10 million
100 billion or 100 million a billion 10
billion trillion billions yeah i have
all of that i think is i think the top
is 100 trillion dollars and it's crazy
because the value of the note itself
isn't as valuable as the paper it's
printed on like literally the paper is
more valuable it's like the penny yeah
exactly yeah that's a perfect analogy
yeah that's incredible that's insane
it's like the uh the dollar bills after
you know germany did that thing and
people started burning them because it
was cheaper to burn
dollar bills instead of buy fuel yeah
and also
remember venezuela has another
problem as well so venezuela's money is
beautiful i have a collection of those
as well they have like beautiful artwork
on their money which is also completely
worthless unfortunately
geez and do they allow bitcoin in
venezuela and zimbabwe to my knowledge
right now i don't know i'm not keeping
up with it see you really when you talk
about bitcoin it sells me on it so hard
maybe i'm just a little too
impressionable and juvenile but like
yeah you're really selling me on it uh
audrey doesn't even have to say anything
he just says the word bitcoin jack's
like
bitcoin good
wait a minute but but why do i have to
sell you on it what is a non-selling
point for you that means you're
that means you're a verse to it why
don't you like it then well it just went
from like 60 000 20 000 and for anyone
look i have very limited knowledge of
cryptocurrency yeah and just from any
outsider seeing something do something
like that when compared to like index
funds which are nice and safe or real
estate which doesn't generally do the
same thing in such a short span of time
it's very very scary
but first i want to thank our sponsor
upstart hearing the credit card balance
month after month can feel never ending
and trust me guys i've been there and
tons of americans have experienced
financial hardship in the last year so
just know that you're not alone upstart
is the fastest and easiest way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online you can consolidate all of your
debts into one easy fixed monthly
payment and upstart knows that you're
more than just a credit score and that's
why they take into account your current
employment and income to find you a
smarter rate and if you have just five
minutes you can go check your rate
upfront all online if you're borrowing
between one thousand and fifty thousand
dollars and you can receive the funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today by going to
upstart.com
ich that's upstart.com ich don't forget
to use our code so that they know we
sent you loan amounts will be determined
from your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application upstart.com
ich thank you so much upstart for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
you know so i do allocate a certain
portfolio percentage mainly just
listening to what graham says you know
it's a three to five percent and that's
kind of what i'm doing i'm not like yeah
what if you it's surprising that you say
that jack because you're the guy who
invested you had like 16 grand invested
in doge points i was just about to say
that says the most volatile thing ever
that's different it was going up
okay and that's going to only goes up
bitcoin could go down a lot of that was
about principle and honestly i'm gonna
say it a lot of it was about proving you
wrong
[Laughter]
just because i was
but i just want to say it is lower today
than the point i told you to sell at
originally it's lower today than the
point you yes yeah but i sold that twice
what you told me to sell at well i've
been telling you i've been telling you
to sell along the way
but it's the point being if i sold it
the first time you told me to sold i'd
be up like 100 bucks still it's still
lower than that point where i was like
hey you should probably sell what's your
most speculative investment right now
right now well i got uh probably the
power of like
eight to nine hundred shares of palantir
oh wow so you mean options trading well
i have three he calls it the power of
the power well like like i got some
options yeah okay so i have like three
or four call options leaps so like way
out in 21 22 way in the money so like
strike price i'm talking like seven
dollars fifty cents ten dollars and then
i think i have four or five hundred
shares so like eight eight hundred i
effectively i like how you just use
options trading language and you're like
oh for people who don't know what
bitcoin is
effectively i'm owning you know 800 or
whatever 800 shares yeah
what are they worth
26 bucks
and the i mean the grand total value of
them i'm not sure so like the the
options that i bought were about a
thousand dollars each so three thousand
dollars and then four or five hundred
shares of palantir i guess would be like
fifteen
fifteen grand yeah fifteen grand fifteen
thousand yeah so like 18 thousand
dollars in palantir and that's like for
me that's like a ton of money that's
like your portfolio value in total
wait so what do you have so what are you
asking what do you ask the question
exactly i want to compare your
investment that you consider is the most
volatile or the most risky to your
actual investment portfolio so you're
asking how much money do i have in the
stock market well just in general how
much are you investing wait so let me
get this straight so you're you're
asking
[Laughter]
no i'm just i'm just curious yeah okay
so ask my permission all right in robin
hood i think i have like 55 000
in vanguard index funds i probably have
like 80 to 90 000
and then in
m1 finance i have about 70.
so 150 so about 200 200 000. okay is
that 215 maybe 15 15 220 yeah and that's
how much i have invested in the stock
market and that counts palantir
yeah and that counts volunteer which is
about 15k yeah that's that's not bad
that's less well palantir is a it's like
a seven
yeah
in the last year and it's a newer tech
stock it's a little more volatile but
then again i like the stocks
so i guess that's more speculative
i have more money in individual stocks
like apple i think i have like
thirty thousand dollars in apple but
then again i wouldn't consider that more
speculative than having eighteen pounds
absolutely but seven percent is not that
much so if i were you i would definitely
swap that seven percent palantir with
bitcoin and no problem you'd be fine i
have money in bitcoin i have five to
seven percent bitcoin five to seven
percent all right so you're fine yeah
now why don't i i don't know
no no no i'm just saying now you're
making me want to go to maybe 10 15
percent
honestly you could go 15 bitcoin i have
the risk tolerance yeah that's the thing
i'll tell you this i put 10 of my net
worth when i reached a million in
bitcoin at the end of 2020
and like pretty much 10x that at its
peak
so crypto by no intention of my own kind
of became
30 to 40 percent of my net worth so you
put in how much initially uh 100 grand
which was what percent
at the time about 10 10 and then it is
now
about 40 30 30 40. which is how how much
money
uh roughly a million
oh yeah
yeah roughly that's pretty good that's
incredible that's it's really good yeah
so i'm looking for places to put it wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait it
turned from a hundred thousand to a
million yeah so you said it five x no i
said it no tenants that it's people i
think that's our title right there yeah
that's peak got it so who got the title
yeah that's incredible wow andre i had
no idea it was like that man yeah no
it's really cool but i've been investing
in bitcoin since 2014 i just didn't have
that much money to put into it at that
time and i didn't really fully
understand it and i'm still trying to
understand it it's like the longer
you're in bitcoin the more you learn and
the more you realize how much you don't
know about it see i think that's a
that's a little
hard to stomach for new investors that
aren't so familiar with bitcoin it might
deter them it's like if they think that
buying bitcoin is much more complicated
than buying a house which to a lot of
people probably does seem like that
because people have houses right uh then
it's gonna deter a lot of people like
getting and starting investment
properties is hard for people to stomach
because it's just like you have to know
how to fix this you got a no contract
you're gonna know this that's not true
the difference between real estate and
bitcoin is that real estate you need a
lot of money to get started with
relatively speaking with bitcoin if you
try to introduce bitcoin from a price
appreciation perspective if you're like
hey i've got a cool opportunity for you
to 10x your money that's terrifying i
would never take that investment sure
that's why if i'm talking to somebody
about bitcoin i'm never going to say
look how much money i've made with it
i'm going to tell them about the federal
reserve and i'm going to paint this
picture of how money works and what it
is and how it's exchanged and what
bitcoin you know the bitcoin story in
this world and i think once you
understand the monetary system
relatively you have to understand it to
the full degree but just a little bit of
the basics i think you start to
understand that bitcoin is not a risk at
all if you look at it from a price
perspective which is what i think graham
was doing for a really long time
then it's absolutely risky it seems like
a scam is like i don't want to do this
so i wouldn't think about it in terms of
price i would think about it in terms of
the narrative
and its place in in the world the use
cases do make a lot of sense but then
again it is just so much information
because it is like it's so new it's
overwhelming and you know i feel like we
haven't even explored its its full
capabilities yet so like i said i think
it could deter some newer investors and
i'm sure if there was some sort of like
bitcoin and psycho encyclopedia or
something that people could access with
like a simplified version if you know of
any called youtube it's called andre's
channel that's true i'm not a crypto
channel but i do do a lot of crypto
content and
the thing that i guess upsets me the
most is that
a few years from now the people that are
gonna that are learning about bitcoin
now that are just getting their feet wet
they're going to miss the boat in the
next few years it's going to be
unattainable to even own one bitcoin
really oh yeah
like i said countries are going to buy
in institutions are going to buy in i
wouldn't be surprised if one day each
bitcoin is worth a million bucks that'll
happen i think before 2030. see but if
you are that bullish on it yeah why 30
to 40 considering you have such a strong
income and that's not going anywhere and
you you have a loan on your house do you
still have debt on it you paid it on
cash yeah right so why not unfortunately
yes why not just go in on bitcoin you
could invest a million dollars into into
an investment property or two and then
that will basically ensure that you're
safe for the rest of your life
considering your current house paid off
and then just everything else bitcoin no
that's a great point and the reason i'm
not doing that is because i'm also risk
averse and i think there are things that
we don't know that we don't know and you
don't know what's going to happen so i
mean i fully believe in bitcoin and if i
was a bigger risk taker that would be
the smartest move right now because
bitcoin is going to appreciate far more
than anything the stock market's going
to do in the next 10 years
selling me on it yeah selling me on it
yeah why don't you go up to like oh yeah
so so for you bitcoin has got to be what
30 percent yeah
yeah
it's not bad honestly yeah i think from
here on out even if you just invest 20
of your income back into bitcoin
it's still pretty good yeah now i feel
like i have a pretty good ratio 20 to 30
percent of my net worth in bitcoin as it
is at a million that's not bad i feel
good with that
first we want to thank grammarly for
sponsoring this episode jack you know
what recent time saving tips i recently
found what if you shower with your
clothes on you're effectively doing
laundry at the same time wait but then
never mind but alex do you know what's
been saving me time i'm installing
tinder no
well yeah but also our sponsor today
grammarly when you want to save time
throughout your day and want to work
more efficiently it's the little things
that really start adding up and
grammarly premium gives you real time
suggestions on your writing wherever you
are for example when i dm guests to come
on the podcast i want to make sure that
my message comes across clearly and
accurately the first time with grammarly
premium's clarity suggestions i make
sure i'm not using any repeated or
unnecessary words and their vocab
suggestions offer replacements for
overused words and phrases and with
their browser plugin and mobile app i
can use grammarly premium no matter
where i'm at and with the free version
of grammarly anyone can be protected
from spelling grammar and punctuation
mistakes and actually that means you too
alex stop letting autocorrect duck up
these sponsor scripts hit send with
confidence and let your message come
across much more clearly with grammarly
premium get 20 off grammarly premium by
signing up at grammarly.com
iced coffee thank you so much grammarly
for sponsoring this episode and back to
the podcast
especially in the next 10 what are your
thoughts now on ethereum because
everything happening with ethereum
lately
is actually really interesting and now
i've started to buy more ethereum when
it dipped below i don't know 3500 it
dipped around like 32 i started buying
back in right and i was not buying
ethereum i think i said on the
millennial money podcast that i was only
going to buy ethereum when it dropped
below 18. or there was like 19 and i did
a little bit but uh now it's like 32 and
it's that seems like a decent price to
me how many coins do you have 50 60 50
60. that's really good i have so far
about 100 of them i i'd like to have
more
but
yeah i think i was going to crush it
next year i think especially just
because they're going to go to the
proof of stake model at that point it's
going to be insane
so for some people that may not
understand ethereum to the full extent
because i know a lot of people say
ethereum is way stronger currency than
bitcoin i hear that a lot right like a
lot of people die for ethereum why like
what is that argument simplified oh gosh
at its simplest core i would say the
reason people say that is because
bitcoin is deflationary and as a
currency you don't want deflationary
currencies because deflationary
currencies incentivize people to hoard
on right they like just hold on to their
money it's like i'm not going to spend
it
ethereum has a higher print rate to
where it's considered inflationary so
there's an endless supply of ethereum
right now there is technically there is
yes now in 2022 when we go to proof of
stake which is a different consensus
model
we'll have a 90 i believe don't quote me
on this but a 90
issuance
cut
so the the rate at which we create
ethereum will be cut by 90
in 2022. at that point it'll still be an
inflationary currency but it'll be
substantially less and do you know why
they're doing that is the inflation rate
a little too high at its current state
they're just restructuring the
incentives that aligns more with proof
of stake rather than what does that do
work
how does that help proof of stake to me
it seems like they do that and it boosts
the price up for everybody else
yeah that's what it seems like it's more
like
selling it yeah it's like the fed kind
of like you know protecting inflation
but they're boosting the market up it
seems like this is like well it works
better but it's also going to i wouldn't
say it's like a marketing gimmick it's
not it's not a marketing game because
just instead of the fees going to the
miners the fees would instead go to the
people holding the coins that's the
proof of stake right so if you're
holding the coins you are the one that
gets the fees rather than the miners so
it's it's less a marketing gimmick and
it's more yeah but a mechanic yeah but
if they're if they're issuing 90
less
that's going to incentivize people to
hold on to it and use it less as a
currency for its intended purpose right
it's too early to say i think i think we
should wait and see but
all currencies in their current form are
are bad currencies just because they're
very slow and expensive to use like
bitcoin for example the block time is 10
minutes right that means if i was to buy
something at the store right now not to
mention the fact that it's like five
dollars to even spend a bitcoin which
makes no sense if i'm gonna buy
something that's five dollars i'm gonna
have to wait potentially up to ten
minutes to check out which
would be really lame right it's like
wait in line for ten minutes people
behind me be really upset
so on layer one bitcoin is not a good
currency neither is ethereum we have to
go to a second layer it's kind of like
think of it like dimensionally we have
to go to a higher dimension at higher
level to interact with these currencies
but that's a whole other enchilada that
if you want to get into that
[Laughter]
do we want to get into that i do
yeah so are you saying like like how
robin hood's not technically like
trading the stocks like because i think
we talked about this last time but this
whole new enchilada would be something
you trade on top yes of of it that
basically just signifies it but it's not
actually exactly and it has a faster
transfer speed yeah and then once that
transfer occurs then it has the like
it's it's it's slowly pushing this log
like yes the lower end so it kind of i
hate this enchilada talk it reminds me
of like
the hispanic food yeah bro it's great
it's like we're going from gold where
it's like it was expected it was
difficult to like hey i'm going to pay
you an x amount of gold but i have to
find a way to store it so instead we're
going to create this dollar that
signifies what gold should be so i just
paid we pay in dollars that's redeemable
for gold yeah graham's ahead of the
curve he knows how i'm going with this
but yeah but as soon as this upper so
enchilada gets established then it will
be quicker yeah that would have any time
horizon on this yeah then it's like mr
rice then it's the beans yeah it's a
full meal
yeah think of the ethereum that within
like the like the salsa on top like
guacamole if you will
you know
okay so what you were saying when the
gas fees are like sour cream
i'm making stuff
let's just keep it going
so what you said with robin is
absolutely true what we're trading in
robin is just derivatives right the
representation of the shares and not
necessarily the shares themselves that's
how bitcoin is trying to become a
currency is through something called the
lightning network which i know you've
heard of before
and the lightning networks like imagine
if graham and i wanted to interact with
each other and the lightning network is
a bunch of nodes that are all connected
to each other and if graham and i
connect maybe graham and i are also
connected to starbucks or to
uh what's the uh what's the coffee brand
bankroll
bankroll oh sorry this is smooth now for
sale at bankrollcoffee.com
faker coffee all right so let's just say
that we're all connected to all these
different businesses
this money bitcoin would be routed
through our channels so if you and i
wanted to send bitcoin to each other
rather than transact on layer one which
is expensive we would open a channel
together we would deposit our bitcoin
enough to cover the cost of those
transactions we would transact
infinitely instantaneously cheaply and
when we're done we can close out our
channels and we can settle then on the
layer one does that make more sense yeah
totally so how often would layer one
settle is this something like i'm gonna
put like 50 grand bitcoin in this
account trade instantaneously and like
every week it settles or
right that's a good question so
initially it seems like we'd be closing
it all the time but opening a channel
and closing it you have to pay a fee on
layer one so it kind of doesn't make
sense so if you want to create a channel
you're probably not going to close it
for a very long time
so i will say that like and i know i'm
going to upset a lot of people that
believe in the lightning network but the
lightning network is something that's
been promised to us for i want to say
like the last six years now and it's
been perpetually two years away and it's
not
i mean it's here but not to the degree
that we'd like to see it just because
the technology itself is so so so
complicated that
okay so let's get deeper so bitcoin
works on uh game theory it's an
incentive theory where humans are
incentivized to be greedy
because we are we're humans are greedy
right so bitcoin works because we're
greedy that's why we have miners they
get paid fees miners are not doing this
altruistically they're doing it to get
paid these fees right
the lightning network is not necessarily
aligned with the right game theory in
order for the lightning network to work
game theory kind of falls apart because
a lot of lightnings i guess security
issues stem from people needing to be
altruistic they need to not screw each
other over there aren't so many fees and
stuff like that i'm not going to get
into it because even i don't i don't
understand the extent of how it works
but just know that game theory doesn't
work on this second layer as much people
have to be trusted to do the right thing
bitcoin works precisely because you
don't need to trust me to do the right
thing i have no choice
bitcoin works the way that it works
because of game theory
and if you develop a new technology to
try to interact with it on
it breaks down because now it's a
completely separate thing and so just as
graham was saying when we had gold it
had its own problems right that was base
layer one it was heavy it was expensive
it didn't make sense we created dollars
that represented pieces of gold which we
then interact with right
but at some point we got rid of gold and
well at some point we printed so much
paper that it didn't even represent that
piece of gold anymore
so that was the issue we came across and
one of the arguments that i think graham
was about to bring up is that we could
experience the same thing on lighting
where we're creating so many of these
derivative coins that may not be it
detaches yeah exactly it detaches from
base layer one that's that's one of the
arguments but but a deeper argument
beneath that is game theory which again
is just the technology doesn't work if
you're gonna be selfish because there
are times at which you'll have a choice
uh do i steal money from this person or
do i not and when that happens with
money it just falls apart now again i'm
gonna upset a lot of people in the
crypto space like oh andre doesn't know
he's talking about the lighting network
probably but it becomes very complicated
and for for me i'm not 100 convinced
that the lightning network will ever be
created it'll never really exist to the
degree that we think about it but even
so even let's just say that the
lightning network fails and it just
can't exist right let's just assume that
let's assume the worst bitcoin will
still be more
more likely to be worth a million
dollars by 2030 even if it does not
become the currency of the world so you
don't think by dangling this carrot of
the lightning theory or the lightning
whatever it's
increasing the price of bitcoin drawing
more attention very little to do what i
think the the average person has no idea
what the heck lightning network is i
yeah i mean i've heard of it before but
i did not i don't even think it's priced
in it's not priced in though
so if they were to say oh we're not
going to do the lightning thing it's not
going to i don't think it's going to
what it is it almost reminds me of like
tesla's autonomous taxi network
it's not really priced in i don't think
it is i besides kathy would believe in
oh you know it's gonna be 3 000 a share
right i don't think the average investor
is looking at that and be like yeah
that's going to be an autonomous taxi
network in five years from now that
that's that sure we're gonna buy that
but there's so many things elon has said
that i don't know if it's priced into
the stock because he's promised the
world and he's promised just everything
yeah i don't know how much of it like
you said is priced in or not but i feel
like every time i talk about bitcoin
like we're getting really into the weeds
here it probably puts people to sleep
but i i think game theory is super
fascinating
that is fascinating
i like it yeah bitcoin works because
people are greedy and they're selfish
and bitcoin
works because it relies on that i'm glad
i got the answer to ethereum and why
that like people like that so much did
you do an ethereum joke i'm doing
ethereum on the side a little bit yeah a
little here yeah i think i'm actually
nearly 50 50 ethereum bitcoin
and then i'm like i got like a thousand
dollars in litecoin um don't know what
it does yeah okay so just someone told
me let me ask you this why isn't
litecoin the next thing to like blow up
because it reminds me a little bit of
like dogecoin in a sense where it's like
you see it on robinhood right and you're
like wow it's it's it's cheap relative
to everything else let's buy this
why aren't people why is why has nobody
done that with litecoin yet yeah that's
a good question i think the reason is
and i could be wrong two reasons number
one because it's an old coin right it's
not exciting anymore it's not like oh
guess what somebody created this new
technology gets a lot of hype right so
it's old news number one number two i
think it lost momentum and steam when
the creator of litecoin
sold out and he just sold all of his
position and he left the project that's
what dogecoin did
true
true but for some reason it didn't have
a stain on that project the same way
that it did for litecoin people just had
a really bad experience when that
happened and i think that kind of killed
the momentum of litecoin
and it just never came back
part of me always looked at like going
to be like you know what maybe just
throw like 50 100 grand in it oh wow it
did well for me so far litecoin yeah
well the only reason i say that is
because it just seems like just in terms
of human psychology when you're looking
at the stats you have do you have
dogecoin the least expensive
and then litecoin right robin hood
yeah actually a lot of investors will do
this they'll look at the top five or
let's say coin i don't know what what it
is on coinbase like the top five but
like you said if they see bitcoin at
forty thousand and ethereum at four
thousand they see litecoin at a hundred
dollars 200 it's like oh well of course
this one is cheaper yes and so people
will invest in it shortly yeah now i'm
not saying that that's any
representation of value or what it means
it's a good deal i'm just like
psychologically oh yeah i i bet a lot of
people do that with dogecoin they looked
at it being like it's a fraction of a
cent
let me buy a hundred dollars worth 100
that's what happened ethereum classic as
well yeah ethereum classic i think was
100 200 and i was like oh great this is
like a discounted ethereum yeah people
bought into it now if you want to hold
on to it for the long term i think is a
whole different question i wouldn't be
willing to but knowing crypto i know
like a year from now people can be like
oh that andre he's an idiot look like
coin's at 10 grand now yeah well
i would be shocked but i could honestly
see litecoin going from like 120 to
500 bucks 600 just at least something
relative because even when you look at
the recent like when when bitcoin hit
60k
litecoin basically just hit its all-time
high in 2017. okay it never went beyond
that see for me whenever we talk about
this kind of stuff that to me is like
the epitome of gambling and i and i saw
this in 2017 when all these icos were
being created and people were like yeah
but there's new technology and it's
going to go to the moon and
the exact same reasons and you could be
100 right
but i feel like at this point because we
have bitcoin and ethereum which are
taking like 90 market share
if you're not gonna invest in those and
you're just gonna speculate on the other
ones to me that's literally no different
than going to the casino and playing
blackjack you could be 100 right or you
could be wrong and it goes nowhere and
you lose all your money like if you want
to take that risk that's fine but i
think that
fuels the narrative of crypto being
speculative is like when people think
like that i don't think you'd lose your
money i would think you lose the
opportunity cost of not investing in
something else um i don't know i feel
like if you really focused on bitcoin
and ethereum if you know that's a
surefire bet
like yeah long-term
long-term degree 100 so why speculate
short-term like i feel like that's what
really scares people off is this talk
when you're like oh my god my head's
exploding with information bitcoin
ethereum is so complicated and it's like
now let me introduce you to litecoin and
dogecoin and like you're just like dude
forget about it
it just gets too speculative so you
think that bitcoin and ethereum not like
literally but are really kind of the
only like legitimate ones no no not not
true no i think there's going to be a
few cryptocurrencies in the future that
are going to be a big part of the
economy i don't know which ones
i mean people speculate like cardano is
going to be maybe in ethereum but right
now it's really maybe bitcoin and
ethereum not to give you like not to
force a hot take on you right right but
maybe only bitcoin ethereum honestly i'm
not like an expert in any of this stuff
not bitcoin not ethereum not even like
altcoins so i can't answer that for you
there are other people that are like way
more knowledgeable about this stuff
i'm pretty sure there will be i don't
know what they are and i would if i have
bitcoin at ethereum this is something
warren buffett by the way uh something
he said he said if you have one good
idea for an investment and i'm
paraphrasing
your second best idea will never be as
good as your first
so if you know that bitcoin is your best
idea let's say or ethereum
why would you ever go anywhere else if
you know that you only have one best
idea right that's probably why he's
worth like a hundred billion dollars
yeah it doesn't make sense to
to to stray away
huh
so what's up with this cardano huh yeah
what is it what does cardano do how much
is that going to be worth
what's your price target
when you've been trying to get charles
hoskinson the creator of cardano on
youtube but and and he followed me on
twitter and i reached out to him but he
hasn't responded yet so i'm waiting but
i'd love to have him on if you're
watching this andre wants to have you on
charlotte i would love to have charles
on he's really really great he's
knowledgeable yeah do you know anything
about cardona what does it do no i i
don't i don't even want to comment on
that because i know people can be like
no idea we dug it about so i'm not going
to try that's fine neither do i and it's
so crazy because with crypto it's so
intense like with stocks there's there's
only so much information you have to
look into to be like okay i think this
is a worthwhile stock to get into this
this company's
balance sheet looks healthy enough to
where it looks undervalued i'm going to
invest in it yeah well with crypto it's
like there's it's like a never-ending
black hole of information so it's like
oh what about bitcoin what about
ethereum what about cardano that makes
sense you don't know one nuance and then
people just jump on you for it so you
miss one why don't we call out some
scams what are some things
what are some things that you would say
like that's questionable no that's
literally putting me on the chopping
block with crypto it's like you say one
wrong thing
we've moved on to like a newer era of
investing where
if you say anything bad about anything
even if it's a blatant scam like
what was it bitconnect bitconnect was
even at that time if you had said big
connect is a scam you would have been
destroyed
why do you think people take it so
seriously i think like take it
personally yeah that's a good question
because the people that invest in the
most speculative investments generally
are not i would say the most clued in
and the most
i want to say intelligent but the most
maybe
educated about what they're doing
and they're as a result probably not the
wealthiest either and so to them these
investments represent
their escape to freedom like it's it's
like don't get in the way between a
mammal and it's food like if you get in
the way you're going to get mauled so it
doesn't matter what you say about these
investments if you have nothing positive
to say
just get out of the way and don't say it
yeah you know what it reminds me of a
little bit that uh the fact that you say
anything negative could influence the
price oh absolutely that cryptocurrency
and because of that it's costing them
money right so if if i say i don't like
this stock and the stock price goes down
a cent that's costing somebody something
exactly and that could be their
livelihood whether that's right right or
wrong it's literally taking food off
their yeah yeah yeah if you hate on
index funds no one's like
you know here's the thing like i talked
so much uh crap about bit connect back
in the day i got so much hate and yes
i remember one of my big connect videos
was more dislikes and likes which is
like never happens on youtube unless you
really mess up but i'm like i'm right
about this
at what point do you got to be like i'm
i'm doing a public service i'm
protecting people because eventually i'm
going to be right
like
what can i save 100 people from
investing in this thing and losing their
money if in the short term it causes you
know some people to question their
investment and get angry yeah that's a
really good question i guess that comes
down to who you choose to be as a person
and i guess i've chosen not to be the
moral arbiter of truth
when it comes to things like i'll just
let people find out for themselves and i
don't want to stand in anybody's way of
making or losing money if that's what
they want to do i want to talk about
what i enjoy and what i think is the
best investment and that's what i think
and i'm not going to try to put anyone
else down even if i believe that it's a
scam
uh completely unrelated to scams or
anything andre there's this video that
you took down about this coin yeah um
you know unrelated to you know what we
were talking about uh what can you see
you know what can you say about that
coin you know without naming the coin oh
gosh no we didn't what coin is it oh is
it
it's not even talking yeah we could talk
okay this is the first time yeah wow
i don't know much about it other than
the video that i made on it so just for
anybody unaware that was called the
million token right from tech lead
um so he released that token and i guess
when he launched it it was supposed to
be backed one dollar for every coin that
he released and it was only supposed to
be a million well it turns out that i
think he initially put in like 50 000
into it and it didn't have the full
million but by that point when he was
quote unquote exposed for not having
done that the project was so valuable
that he could easily just liquidate his
holdings and represent the million one
for one so it was just more of like a
political
witch hunt i guess right yeah and so a
creator uh coffeezilla made a video on
tech lead and they had this like what i
like to call the most toxic
collaboration on youtube i've ever seen
it was interesting it was interesting
like there's back and forth yeah i can't
stand those uh when they're just like
back and forth arguing with each other
right and it's so interesting because i
feel like tech lead
really got coffeezilla to play into this
project like he played him like a fiddle
he really did this intentionally now
when i released my video and i saw
coffeezilla release his i was like oh
gosh well if it's true and if this
project really is a scam i should
probably take my video down because i
don't want anybody else to get hurt
and for doing that i started to notice
like my youtube channel started to get
negative comments and i'm like what's
going on that's when i found out what
was going on
and to this day none of it makes any
sense to me because even though i took
my video down
tech lead
and coffeezilla have made these videos
back and forth with each other meanwhile
i take my video down you have to
remember tech lead is making money off
of his project he's making money off of
his videos coffeezilla is making money
off of tech leads videos they're having
this toxic collaboration where they're
both making money off of each other and
i'm the idiot in the middle that's not
making money off of anything
and i'm just like gosh i should just
take this video down because it doesn't
make sense i think the moral of the
story is to keep the video up because
once the video's on youtube for the most
part it's it's up there somebody's
downloaded it somebody's reacted to it
somebody's responded to it well somebody
could find it and then if you take it
down the immediate go to is what is he
hiding right why did he have to take it
down he wouldn't take it down if he
didn't do something wrong right right
and that's why i've always had this this
philosophy worth like if i post
something up there i'm gonna keep it up
right and it's just because otherwise if
you take it down now it's like
you know i'd rather yeah generally i
agree with you i took it down and i
waited until tech lead made a response
that's what i said i was like i'll wait
until the creator makes a response that
makes sense i'll put it back up tech
lead never really made a like a
non-sarcastic response that i understood
because all of his videos are very
sarcastic so i watched all of his videos
but it didn't feel as though he had
dressed directly it was like character
assassinations back and forth what's
interesting to me though is that after i
made my community post explaining what
happened explaining my position
coffeezilla made a comment on my
community post that's like oh well you
know good job you made the right
decision
and i'm like oh that's cool
and then i'm like wait a minute these
these two guys are giving each other so
much toxic attention and this project is
getting so much attention and
coffeezilla's making money off of this
project because they're making videos
about each other how is it my
responsibility to take my video down
meanwhile he's making
five or six videos on his million token
it's just kind of it's a double standard
it doesn't make any sense because i have
nothing to benefit from coffeezilla's
making money tech leads making money and
yet coffee's like oh good job taking it
down like wait a minute should it be
your responsibility to not make videos
about this either because you're giving
it way more attention than my one video
did
well i think the difference is that
coffeezilla
really called it out negatively i think
your video from what i remember was
neutral it was neutral yeah it wasn't
positive it wasn't negative it was right
in the middle right and so people can
interpret that however they like they
could interpret that positively or they
could just be i'm not interested kathy
zillow was very much on the side of this
is bad this is negative these these are
these are these these
lies sure um but he's smart enough to
know and so is tech lead and so is
coffeezilla they're both smart enough to
know that regardless of what the message
is positive negative or neutral
the end result is that you're still
bringing more attention to a project
that
coffee zilla otherwise believes is a
scam i don't know
look you're right you bring more
attention to it but at the same time i
bet that the net change in people buying
and selling millionaire token
considering coffee zone making these
videos is probably fewer people no or
you think so i know so
that more people bought it after
coffeezilla made his videos yes but then
again wouldn't these people just be
negligent
no matter where they go into it is this
like at least knowing that like hey this
is what's going on let me take a risk on
it the general rule of thumb for crypto
and this isn't always true but it
happens more often than you think is
that whenever a project is having
negative publicity and negative
attention
that's when people buy in more because
they see it as an opportunity they're
like oh it's dipping i should buy it now
and whenever somebody praises a project
and believe it or not i've seen this on
my own youtube videos whenever i say
something is going to the moon or
something is a really cool project
that same day the project will dip and
that's just because people assume
they're like oh well if andre found out
about this that means we're at the top
right now the public is talking about
this
so to answer your question that
attention that they brought on the
project actually had a net benefit
effect and i i'm telling you both of
those guys are smart enough to
understand that
so i i don't want to be the mascot of of
you know the scapegoat for all of this
negative attention that's why i took the
video down
i get that i don't know
it's as far as my thoughts not that not
that anyone asked for it right i'm
pretty much neutral on this too i think
a lot of the accusations that were made
not the biggest deal to me i would see
these things and just be like all right
there's i think there's a lot of nuance
there and like not putting up a full
million it doesn't really seem needed
there is no evidence that he cashed out
he made money on the project but he
should make money on the project because
he created it i don't see that as an
issue
it didn't have the most success i mean
it it moved right when it launched i
mean gosh it went all the way up to 200
and something it had like a 200 million
dollar market cap which was nuts now
it's down to like 16 15 million so it's
so whoever bought it 200 and it's now
down at 16. they lost a lot of money
that's a lot for sure but for the people
who bought in at a dollar
i it was a smart concept for sure i mean
it was part of me thinks it's like not
that i would ever do this but like why
didn't i think of it it was one of those
things oh yeah where it's like putting
up a million bucks as a social
experiment
and just back it with your own money for
a million bucks i mean like there's
nothing you could lose on that i'm not
discounting that as something i wouldn't
try like i would love to do that at some
point and just because he's done it
doesn't mean that it can't be done again
i feel like that's something i would
love to try at some point i i don't know
like i don't have plans for it but i'm
just saying like you said it's a great
idea it's a good idea a great idea i bet
he had to have had so many lawyers
looking through this because the the
thing with tech lead is that uh he's not
dumb no he's
really smart and i think he he just
thinks on like a like a
a level outside of what like most people
are are in this like sphere of like
where they think i think tech lead is
like over here and just think of all all
these abstract thoughts and ideas and
what could happen this and that so i
think i'm thinking he's planned like
five moves ahead and isn't gonna get
sued is not gonna subject himself to the
sec
but there were some things he was saying
like it could go to the moon this could
be like
some of that wording
it kind of got me where it's like
it feels like a security it does
speaking of securities yeah did you see
uh coinbase being i did regulated
potentially for the lend product yeah so
for those not familiar so because i was
doing a lot of research on this today
are you making a video about this
tomorrow audrey
are you going to make a video about it
no comment ah
yeah
we always do this and do you you know
the the thing what is it it's thursday
today yeah thursday day right okay you
know what the thing is we we gotta we
gotta settle this really quick before we
go into this people think that we
collaborate on video ideas right and we
post at the same time so let's address
this let's squash this beef right sure
sure why
why does sometimes you post at the same
time as me we both you you were posting
at 3 15 yes and you went to 3 30. yeah i
posted 3 30. right and i've been doing
that for five years that's true so
the reason that i did that i think i
started at three originally then i went
to 3 15. and it's not because i'm trying
to release the video at the same time as
you are it's just genuinely sometimes
i'm so late on my edit that i'm just
like oh gosh i can't make my 3 15. so my
next slot is 3 30. got it and sometimes
it's 3 45 or 4 whenever it might be but
i try to make 315 but it just doesn't
always work
um that's generally why it's nice at 3
15 because once they're done watching
your video yeah they hop on over to
grams so let's do that 3 15 tomorrow for
me and 3 30 for you i can't promise you
something maybe we'll post at three yes
sometimes i post to three because
because my strategy sometimes is posting
on an off hour and people are like why
is it early yeah if it's breaking news
they realize that like oh my gosh it's a
different new video you can't do that
all the time and if you get like
inconsistent too often they won't watch
it absolutely but like i would say maybe
once to twice a month i'll post early
right that's it
so on occasion i'll do that but i can
i'll try to do that too if i feel like
the video is maybe going to be slow i'll
change up the time yeah it's a
psychological thing yeah for sure but
people always think that we collaborate
on business
we've never been talking about videos
ever or
like we never recorded that would be
horrible and people don't realize that
like if we said like hey let's both make
videos on this topic we're doing both of
us a disservice right both doing the
same topic i think it it waters down the
overall content right for each of us so
okay it just it just so happens that we
i guess just make the same videos
so clearly we're doing the same video
tomorrow so i have something i feel like
i dug really deep into the research for
my video tomorrow
so tonight
yeah who dug deeper who's who went
deeper oh gosh that's that's a loaded
question
uh
yeah there's there's a few interesting
things i found out about i suppose why
coinbase is targeted because like brian
armstrong the ceo of coinbase right he
feels really slighted he's like why it's
not
fair since you're so researched all
right explain the issue with uh
coinbase lend coinbase lend yeah
yeah so coinbase lend is their program
to lend out usdc right the stablecoin at
four percent and they worked with the
sec to try to release this product which
was mistake number one i don't think
brian should have ever contacted the
essex they should have because they're a
publicly traded company and if the sec
cracks down on a product like that when
they're publicly traded that is
disastrous for the stock so they have to
sort of it's better to ask for
forgiveness than it is for permission
that's my philosophy what happened with
robin hood savings account where they
just unleashed it and then yeah
and then yeah the fdic hey and that was
disastrous and they weren't because
they'd be treated and that's not because
they didn't ask that's because they
weren't fdic insured they should have
done that
nothing to do with their permission
but
i would i would beg to differ okay i beg
to differ because it's all it's all in
the interpretation of what they call it
bank account versus cash management okay
fair enough i i think that coinbase
shouldn't have asked permission because
there's another public company which
i'll explain in a second that does have
this product which is voyager they have
a an interest rate program as well so
the lend program so they reached out to
the sec the sec says no you can't right
you can't do this project because that's
considered a security and brian
armstrong the ceo started to tweet storm
saying this is some sketchy behavior by
the sec who are they trying to protect
they're clearly trying to protect the
legacy banking system because we're
paying way more interest on our accounts
than you know the national average of
0.06 whatever it is
so
what i figured out and and there's two
real there's two things there's
something called the howie test which i
don't know if you covered right i did
the howie test and the securities act of
1933. first page jeez yes
first player yeah this is crazy this is
hilarious the first page man
oh my gosh let's drop i'm secretly lying
that's not
[Laughter]
how long is your video it's going to be
yeah it's like 13 and a half 13.50
mine's going to be like 16. oh but he
has like a minute and a half shows and
actually yeah and i'm mentioning
things in there
i mentioned if you want to watch mine
because mine's more brief and condensed
i want to watch mine because i simplify
things a little bit yeah but you'll have
a lot more sponsored messages but mine's
a lot more interesting
no sponsored messages there's two and a
half minutes oh yeah sorry i don't i
don't fill my content with magic tricks
yeah you get sponsors instead you're
making money andre
oh hey hey there's no magic tricks
tomorrow
i'm just saying
but the only magic is that people are
going to watch my video first okay okay
fair enough we covered the two reasons
right we covered the howie test and the
sec but
so i i kind of resp
so i responded to brian like this this
is this is this is what i'm most proud
of that in the video that i said um the
reason that the sec is targeting
coinbase specifically whereas they're
not with voyager is because of how the
interest rate model works on coinbase
versus voyager the interest rate model
on coinbase is through lending
lending is considered a security because
it just is it's a lending product
so it's considered a security because in
2008 when we had the collapse it was a
result of the uh securities lending yeah
right let me clarify actually uh as
somebody's researched this topic it's
not just lending okay lending is total
lending is not a security it's when
you're lending in conjunction with a
pool of other people yeah on the efforts
of somebody else and they say that's the
how we test yeah we're going to cover
this right you're saying but you're
saying that that lending is a security
the fact that you're lending it's not
that you're lending it's you're lending
it i think you're full of other people i
think you're nitpicking
yeah anyway that's not what i was trying
to get at all right what i was trying to
get at is that coinbase's interest rate
model base is based on lending right so
we make money through coinbase if they
have this product out based on the money
they lend out to their clients
okay
voyager is not targeted by the sec even
though it's a public company why
do you know this
uh
i'm letting you show us if you know all
right so the reason that voyager is not
as targeted as for two reasons the size
of the influence of voyager because
they're like exponentially smaller than
coinbase is first reason the second
reason is because their interest rate
model is based on the bid and ask spread
whenever you buy bitcoin on voyager
let's say you bought a thousand dollars
worth of bitcoin they would find you
bitcoin for 999
they pocket the difference with that
dollar of profit they pay you interest
on your money
that is a significantly lower risk model
than lending
does that make sense so they incentivize
you to hold rather than to transact
no that's not what i was trying to
trying to say so the way voyager makes
its money through this interest rate
product right is through basically
scalping your order that's what they say
we don't know if that's actually the
truth
i'm pretty sure it's the truth i would
be shocked if they're making that much
money on scalping
uh bitcoin on the platform to pay if
what their interest rates are probably
the only way they make money right yeah
but that's just one of the ways right
like robin hood right right but but
there but part of the howie test is is
is saying that coinbase is using
this lended usdc to fund business
operations i would be shocked if voyager
was not using your usdc or bitcoin or
whatever to fund business operations in
some way or another they have to maybe
but like i said because voyager is
exponentially smaller
and the influence they have on the
industry is not the same risk model as
lending out our deposits the sec is
looking at coinbase differently because
they are lending our money and that's
what really massively fails the howie
test i would say the biggest thing for
me is just the size the size publicly
traded and they brought this to the sec
and the sec is just against
cryptocurrency in general they want to
really regulate it um
and i think for them upfront there's no
way of making sure that that coinbase
couldn't ponzi scheme it in some way
because they're lending money who's to
say they're not lending money to
somebody else who's lending money to
somebody else letting money somebody
else that's way more tinfoil hat theory
than me is it is it it's possible i i
would be shocked but for the sec to make
sure that isn't happening for the
protection of the people
my position is gary gensler the the
chairman of the sec is not like an evil
dude he just wants to make sure that
2008 doesn't happen again in crypto and
so his approach is to look at every
project and every platform independently
because if what graham said was true if
the sec really hates crypto and they
really want to regulate it they would
have regulated voyager out of existence
yesterday but they haven't yeah so why
because they want to make sure that the
innovation we have in the us based on
crypto is not stifled because if we shut
down crypto and we're like hey lending
stable coins crypto's illegal we're
going to lose so much business and so
much technology it's going to go
somewhere else and they don't want to do
that they want to make sure to regulate
us only so that 2008 doesn't happen
again and coinbase's model is more
conducive to that i don't know what did
they do with ripple
you know they called that a security
right couldn't that be stifling
innovation coinbase had to take it down
well it depends how is ripple making its
money how what is its effect on the
industry again i would argue ripple is a
far bigger project than voyager
i feel like i need to rewatch this
segment
like five times
to understand point being
coinbase was shut down by the sec they
said no crypto lend
uh coinbase came back saying this is
unfair
i think they're going to try to work out
maybe a middle ground or something but
uh sure
overall i don't know i i feel like
things should be a lot looser in terms
of regulation on that but uh yeah also
that's the reason why blockfly is being
regulated by the states yeah they're
getting crap for it because they have
the same interest rate model they lend
our money to their clients again voyager
doesn't do that that's why they're not
looked at as much
what blockfi is but anyway but they say
that again i again i'd just be shocked
that voyager is not doing that because
blockfy could just say oh yeah we're
using our cryptobots to go and trade and
with your money we do this we pay you
back a percent
but they're not i mean they're i think
they're honest probably and uh
that that's bad because they're they're
being honest and and maybe they don't
comply with certain regulations certain
states in the way it's defined but i
would be shocked if voyager is literally
making their money from that yeah i
guess we'll find out yeah but either way
i think our titles are probably gonna be
the same tomorrow too
what's your title i'm not gonna i don't
think it's gonna be i'm mentioning this
you already have you don't have your
time no i literally put title undecided
okay so what i'll do is i'll post uh
after you okay and then when i see your
title i'll make it better sweet sounds
good
but after i get the views
no i don't know i'm probably going to
title it something different it's pr
maybe it's going to be crypto related
i'd say 50 50. okay yeah because i
mentioned a few other things okay yeah
now i'm just focused on on this issue
yeah so if you want to hear this issue
you're saying
i'm regular we have a multitude of
things very exciting things yeah yeah i
talk about five things tomorrow yeah if
you don't want to watch sponsors and the
other two and the other two things then
yeah well if you don't want to waste
your time watching magic tricks who
doesn't fail
just fill it long enough for you to
place mid-roll ads in the video
over here come watch my content
if you don't want to watch magic trees
oh god sorry if you don't want filler
content to try to get it to 10 minutes
yeah go watch monsters
that is so funny that impression was
oh that's nothing all right well we'll
see what's happening i'll watch both
videos thank you i'll let you know thank
you
wow
where did we go for that one that was
really good
what else
yeah oh yeah my newest investment let's
see it all right i want to see you guys
are you guys ready for that yeah i don't
think you're ready love to see it all
right i know what it is do you know what
it is yes i know what it is and this is
going to be eclipse exclusive because
it's a visual content wow yes subscribe
down below to the uh clips channel this
is only going to be available there
since this is a visual right so i show
wait andre to entice them yeah you know
the clips people how much did you spend
on this investment i'm not gonna say how
much but i can say uh what the original
listing was uh listed for yeah yeah that
would be good it was listed for 220
dollars
[Music]
wow that was incredible that was cool
that was so cool i'm so glad i watched
that on the clips exclusive channel
whoa that was awesome it was like time
traveling i know
thank you so much for showing us that
can you believe that jack i really can't
i'd rather watch this than sponsors
well i'd rather watch sponsors than
magic
anyway uh
any what else is going on for you man
like uh personally and you don't really
go into uh your personal life that much
yeah i'm throwing a housewarming party
pretty soon because the house is finally
done which is awesome congrats to me yay
congratulations yeah it was pretty cool
and other than that i'm trying to do
more sponsored videos so i can be like
graham so you could buy a 4gt2
you are going to buy tesla right i was
yeah model y and i still am but they've
pushed the delivery dates like december
from now there's no way you can get
around that
no
i'm not that hot what about a model x
i'm not sure i'm a huge fan of the model
x like it's cool i just i'm not sure i
like the going doors uh-huh cause
they're like they're cool but they're
not as practical as normal doors
because you're driving a civic right now
right no we're driving a corolla oh my
girlfriend i are sharing in corolla and
then corey she got a new job with jeremy
she did that was pretty cool so now cory
works at home so we can actually travel
places together and she doesn't have to
ask somebody for permission to get off
work that's cool which i think is
awesome so what's the next step for you
like what's what's
after this or what's what's coming up in
the next year yeah you're trying to
create an app that is tied to a
cryptocurrency like what tech lead is
doing but it's tied to a game of
investing i want to do everything that
robin hood wished they could do
because it's a game it's not real
investing
it's just like paper trading it's
gamifying investing in a way that's
never been done before
that's right so so it'd be like an app
game yes it'll be like an app game
that's fun to play and that gets people
encouraged and motivated to invest but
it could also like teach them stuff
exactly and the financial incentive
behind it is that there's a crypto
stablecoin that i've created
wow that's interesting yeah
so it sounds an awful lot like a
security no it's a utility token
huh
yeah
when is that gonna launch i don't know
yet we're working on it it's been over a
year now that i've been working who's we
just me and someone else's team from new
york
oh it's working on it yeah but if you
guys are talented crypto people reach
out i'd love help with crypto it's so
complicated
i'm curious how it's when you say a game
is it uh
because robinhood is kind of gamified
investing right make a trade you get
like confetti right it's just like paper
trading
but on like steroids like like all the
gamification is amplified by 10 like you
make a trade like the screen flashes
it's it's some variable value
and is it tied to actual values of
stocks like does it track the market and
then like incorporate that yeah it's
interesting it's real-time data and
everything yeah and the financial
incentive behind it is that you know if
i actually incorporate real stocks or
real money that would be really
potentially scrutinized but if it was a
crypto or a stable coin maybe that's
different so that's what i'm hoping
could you buy with that stable coin
could you buy or is it only used for
like in-app purchases maybe it's
something you huddle for life
i don't know i'm thinking through it
okay yeah
i think it's a pretty cool idea
that is interesting i'd love to like
hear more about it but i'm assuming you
probably don't want to divulge too much
while it's still on the beta yeah either
way it's not yeah i just i'm still
learning about it but even if i tell
people it's it's the thing about apps is
just it's not the idea that's valuable
it's the execution
that's why like one of the things i
actually don't really like is that i
don't know if you experience this with
sponsors is like hey we want you to sign
an nda
it's like i want to i don't know
okay i've had somebody ask me to sign an
nda and i can't stand that like ndas
make no sense they're worthless yeah
yeah it's like dude ideas are a dime a
dozen i don't want to sign your nda and
that's going to prohibit me in from like
working on this idea potentially here's
a great idea banana-powered flying
vehicles if somebody creates that
tomorrow does that entitle me to
royalties
no right so why should an nda
yeah indies are a waste but the app id
is really interesting we got uh with
jeremy it's called the hungry bowl yeah
that's all i'll link to it down below in
the description or anyone who wants to
try that out
but uh we've been going now for a few
months wait was that smooth was that
nice
nice intro
looking directly into the camera like
yeah that'll be down below in the
description where you could sign up and
try it for yourself
let us know what you think let's just
say we got almost 30 000 people on the
app so far it's it's still a work in
progress i would say
uh maybe we're 25 of the way in terms of
doing exactly what we want to do on it
um and there's a few other like ideas
and stuff i want to implement like right
now it's really just like the bare bones
and you're getting in at the ground
floor if you sign up right now it's free
totally friends
no not out there it's a good yeah i like
it as a as a customer of the app i like
it listen if jack likes it that's that's
the best endorsement you could ever get
is your goal to sell it to blackrock for
billions
i don't know i don't know what the goal
is
it's it's something new that's what i
like is it something new it's something
different it's outside of youtube uh
could try a different endeavor i like
that aspect of it whatever ends up habit
i have no clue but i like the fact that
it's not necessarily reliant on myself
it could grow independently of me
and uh it's just it's something a little
bit different it's cool and i think i
think really right now it's it's it's
going in the direction of just
eventually becoming an app that i wish
existed for myself right right now it's
it's it's it still needs more so i
acknowledge that you know what i want to
know though yeah what the people have
going on at home i want to know what
what their lives are doing i'm going to
read the comments yeah
try to reply to as many as i can
let us know what you think of the
sponsors of today's video
down below in the comment section so we
asked what's going on with you and you
didn't say anything about your personal
life you just you said uh you know the
app you're building and stuff so what's
going on with you got no life man i've
got no personal life
yeah i don't have a life i just i'm just
working to do youtube all day where do
you see yourself 10 years from now
about that alive i hope
i don't know i i hope that i'm still
enjoying what i do and i think the most
i ever ask for is just to be happy and
content where i'm at
and beyond that is just speculation i
just like i don't want to predict it i
just want to be happy what about you
graham 10 years from now yeah
uh buckets of money
[Laughter]
hopefully yes hopefully a lot of
sponsors
i don't know definitely i think 10 years
from now um
i want to take it easy a little bit more
yeah yeah that's a good goal
yeah i took uh what was it i took labor
day off yeah i have to say oh man i had
not taken it like a like a and here's
the weird thing i worked that day you
did yeah oh yeah that's where i got all
my reaction videos done oh yeah that was
good but it was it was weird it was like
i told myself i'm just gonna take the
day off
and i got some of the best work done
that day it was the weirdest thing and i
had almost only reacted to stuff okay
true which is but like once you take a
week or two off in your life like purely
without work you'll never be able to go
back because you realize that life's
just about enjoying it not just working
but no but i took the day off and i
thoroughly enjoyed work it was it was a
it was just a fun day where i woke up i
slept and slept in like you know eight
a.m
uh just read the internet for a while
like two hours
uh took a shower a nice breakfast did a
whole bunch of great reaction videos at
a fun time
uh went to the gym for like a solid hour
with the jacuzzi i i think macy and i
would actually heat it up it did
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah so i've used the
jacuzzi quite a bit and uh i found out
that gas is really not expensive at all
how much does it cost uh the gas bill
went from like i think like 15 dollars
like 20 bucks a month so it's like so
that's five bucks
are you leaving it on now uh no not all
the time i just turn it on for probably
like an hour it heats up within about an
hour
so i could turn it on to use it
great for you man yeah graham's got no
soul
i i think you probably
had such a great day because you just
took it easy you know you worked
exactly there was no deadline to be like
yeah oh my god during the week if if i
don't hit the deadlines for every single
day i'm behind and i have to make it up
that's a stressful way of living though
i do take
that's required if you want to continue
growing on the on the platform and
continue like pushing away you have to
do i don't have the luxury of just
you know i'm not saying take off i'm
just saying don't stress about it as
much but you don't think there's there's
a happy medium like a way that you can
right now there's not because i know you
have have are we allowed to announce
that maybe by the end of this year let's
announce it all right yeah so
i think it's good that you took it easy
man you've earned it you don't deserve
it but you don't deserve it but you
earned it uh at some point at some point
they will but uh i love cryptic podcasts
yeah yeah so what are you up to secret
stuff
you can't talk can we talk about it no
oh
what about you oh you know things
really cool stuff working on beyond
scenes can't talk about it though
at some point at some point i want to
just uh scale back a little bit or do
things in a way that's uh
uh
what was i about to say do things that
uh that can free up more of my time so i
think i think if i if i could get some
of my time back it'll really help and be
honest would you use that free time to
enjoy yourself or use it to put it into
other ventures that'll make you i want
to go and make more money i know i i
don't know i want to get really i want
to get really into fitness i don't know
i've had to say that i think yeah i just
want to get ripped
something productive that moves graham
forward i could see yeah i could see
myself if i'm not if if i even just like
get get i don't know an extra 15 hours a
week i'd probably put that in fitness
because i i honestly i looked at uh i
saw that cnbc millennial money video
earlier
i hated the way i looked honestly no
really it was like to see myself because
because i see the difference between
like two years ago and now right and i
think it's just
i'm not net in a place where i like i i
look at myself like weight wise and i'm
like yeah right no i i could get
definitely in shape and i've
sacrificed that so two and a half years
ago when i started youtube i looked so
thin it's like unhealthy but now i feel
like i'm at a better weight but i could
be definitely more yeah for sure so i
was just thinking that do your arms look
like they're really filling out yes
because i'm getting fatter oh pretty
cool i thought it looked good alright
well on that note
wave i just want to say something like
like i do want to mention because i came
back from los angeles and what was that
monday graham yeah
when i came back from los angeles you
seemed in an incredible mood and i
didn't want to mention anything because
i i didn't want to like i didn't want to
say anything but i was like thoroughly
enjoying that like i walked in the door
and you were all like happy and stuff
like that's getting your reaction i know
but like i remember i was walking up i
was walking up to the front door and
graham's coming up from the gym he's all
jack wait wait i turn around like he
watched me
and then and then like he went told me i
probably had to do something
and then i went inside but i remember
like so i boxed his car in and i didn't
have my keys my dad had my keys and and
graham was like oh you gotta like move
the car and everything and i feel like
if this was this was where during like a
time in the week grant will be like i
just beat you no he will
he treats me well like extremely well
but he would definitely like he would be
frustrated you know and it wouldn't be
so fun but then we solved the issue i
was able to to maneuver the car out so
he was able to take the car and we were
having fun while we were doing it it's
all relaxed and just like
problem-solving in a joyous mood you
know and i i really enjoyed like that
monday
and it was awesome spending time with
you man i gotta say the same thing
graham i walked in at uh 8 30
and graham didn't know i was here
because it was labor day and he greeted
me in the nicest way i've ever been
greeted ever because you know what
during the week if if i don't hit that
schedule i'm behind like i gotta get
that that's what it was he got a number
one out of ten video
no the algorithm hasn't been our
friendly now the algorithm is yeah i
know this is despite the algorithm yeah
yeah no it was honestly just to uh just
to take a day off i still got a lot of
work done but uh but to do it like to
feel like i'm really getting ahead and
just to do the things that i wanted to
do that day yeah
and and i was a bit of a you know ahead
on the main channel
so it was awesome it's always a pleasure
to be around you man but monday it was
just
a whole different level like it was
awesome yeah
yeah and that and that weekend we did
the uh went to the grand canyon oh
that's cool i thought it was that i
didn't know it was like that you were
taking the day a little easier yeah or
less pressure but yeah so all right
we'll see awesome yeah
sweet so on that note thank you so much
for coming
thanks andre use my coupon code down
below blockfy.com for slash andre
we'll edit that part out
thanks man i really appreciate it thanks
peace
are we leaving and then it's still
recording and it's like oh yeah
and then are we gonna cut to that camera